greetings I thought I would start out
today rewarding the people who come on
time with another treat you get to
vote
wow okay uh well before anybody else
comes in uh I'm going to allow you to
vote on when you want the term papers to
be due now you thought this you do
everything democratically in this
Society so you have a choice you can
vote for either
Monday the
12 13th 14th or Wednesday the
16th we don't have any votes for any of
those okay now all right all in favor of
Monday the 14th please raise your
hand all in favor of Wednesday the 16th
please please raise your
hand wait a minute what's the what kind
of a democracy is this we don't okay um
everyone else raise your
hand what are you in favor of Scott
you're not you're just an auditor
doesn't matter so I'm in favor of
tomorrow in favor of tomorrow okay Scott
is going to make a lot of friends okay
well uh we had one who wanted it on on
Monday what was the
reason uhuh
well that's not
fair somebody voted for Monday just to
what why not Monday get it over with
Monday oh okay right doesn't matter okay
so uh I I'll uh um take them on
Wednesday then um uh let's see that's um
5:00 p.m. Pacific Daylight time uh in in
my office Pacific Standard Time excuse
me I always make that mistake Pacific
Standard Time in my office in Margaret
Jacks Hall um and or to get to the TA
somehow is are you are you guys still
around yeah so if you can't find my
office you can find them okay so Alan
that's uh do a week from wedes two weeks
from Wednesday is when two weeks from
the previous Wednesday is when your turn
paper is
due okay now my main topic for today
however is something that uh we haven't
talked about this quarter and that is
computer programs that are supposed to
help you in your
writing um and what I'm going to talk
about today is not the state-of-the-art
I'm talking about programs that have
been been around for a long time the
ones that the ones that uh showed the
first results because we don't have the
state of the-art ones here on campus
they cost money and uh nobody uh has has
paid for has paid for them particularly
the the one that I wish I could have
tried on the sample text there's a on on
newer versions of Unix there's a program
called sexist which will look over your
text and and suggest how you could
improve the writing so that you would
avoid sexist possibly sexist terminology
and uh I thought that would be
interesting to apply that to some
classic uh some classic documents
however um also to my own writing of
course but um uh unfortunately I have an
example so that um of that to show you
but um I'm sure that it would also be an
aid like the ones that I'll that I'll be
talking about here um I guess since I
raised the issue of sexism I should
mention that I
was once quoted in the London times for
for saying that it it wasn't
professional to talk about mother and
daughter in a tree structure as Father
and Son in a tree structure and and U I
had a lot of ir male after that point
and um and people are a little more um
what do you call it um
uh well at at the time um you couldn't
tell a joke about about such things and
people aren't quite as uptight about
issues anymore although they're still
difficult and important um
now uh so there's there's two programs
on Navajo that I used called style and
diction and uh and I suppose that a lot
of Unix systems have these These are
these are old these are fairly as I said
uh
introduced uh quite a while ago I don't
know the date on this on this W I'm
sorry I took it away from you Eddie um I
don't know what the date on this is but
this is uh uh but and this just
describes uh probably not the very first
the first manual on it but there's but
these two programs um uh you can feed
them any any uh any file any asky file
whatsoever and it gives gives you
numbers out saying how readable it was
and things like that um and the uh and
uh as you can expect these numbers
aren't um 100%
reliable um but it's but uh and so we as
we look at these programs you'll you'll
see that U obviously the the The
Superficial things that these programs
do um are way below what any what any
human being would ever do reading
reading the text uh still um I think
they're they're useful for two reasons
one is um it's kind of
fun uh but
secondly um it's always useful to have s
some some excuse to read your document
from another point of view and so so
this will this will single out a
sentence and it'll say you know this
sentence uh was was was unreadable for
some reason or other or should be
improved and maybe the sentence uh maybe
the computer is wrong about it but it's
but still it pointed out that sentence
to you which you might not have thought
about again and you'll get you'll get a
better idea anyway even if the computer
was wrong about it I mean this reminds
me again story that fman told he was he
was asked to to go to Oakridge and um
and and in during the war and check on
the the um the the the plans for
developing this this uranium processing
plant there and um and he really he says
he didn't really understand what was
what he he got these huge Blueprints and
so on he really didn't know what it was
about but he he looked the down and he
put his finger down he said oh what
what's this here and the guy looked at
it and said oh my goodness we shouldn't
have had those two things in the same
room or something like this you know and
um so now now uh you know just a
complete blind pointing to the thing you
know but but that that helps and so so
uh it's useful to have a tool like this
even if it's even if it's U not 100%
right now it but it is it it isn't
complet 100% wrong either uh but even
we're if we're completely random it
might be useful sometimes to to do it um
okay now let's take a look at then at U
what it is I have I made a whole bunch
of um sample texts and the first one
that I want to show you is from from Al
a CH a textbook by Alonzo church called
introduction to mathematical logic uh
Tracy picked this out on of my bookshelf
as one that that looked like we could
use as a reasonable one for starting
with Brand X and now this is a book that
I used as a text uh so that was you know
so it's probably not used anymore these
These Days although Trac apparently had
seen it um and um it has a very
ponderous introduction now the the the
introdu the first chapter is something
that um uh uh anyway it's uh it's it's
well written uh as far as as far as the
grammar is concerned you you can't look
at any the sentences and say there's
there are real there are real flaws in
the sentences but it's ponderous it goes
on and Lumbers along um and the
sentences are are U longer and more
complicated than would be necessary to
make the points that he's making on the
other hand almost essentially all
textbooks were were like that at the
time um so anyway here we have a here we
have an example of his uh thing and so
now I'll show you computer output so
we're running
Style on on this and um so I'm running
Navajo as I said and I read in church uh
excerpt here so it gives a readability
grade and it actually gives readability
grades and it has four of them here and
these are on a on a level of uh what
grade level you are and so this would be
a 14th almost a 15th grade student
that's uh What uh junior in college
right and this one um goes little past
senior level right on this there's there
are four different ways of computing
these scores and I'll show you what they
are so you see simple correlations on
two variables that are that are that are
completely linear so the Kincade formula
here gives you the reading grade in the
following you count syllables per word
multiply by 11.8 add 39 * words per
sentence and divide by and and subtract
this other constant here so this is you
know typical thing you get out of Auto a
linear
regression um analyzer you give some
points um they they they started out uh
Navy training manuals they were using
here um and and so people had had had
had rated them and saying this is grade
level five this is grade level 10 and so
on for each one um and then
um uh and then uh uh you Tred to find
the best fit of the of a function of the
form a X plus b y + C equals grading
level done by the by the uh by the
people who assigned the levels and this
was the were the best constants in in
the sense of Le squar or something like
this uh now the next one is the the auto
what they call Auto automatic automated
readability index and this was based on
text from grade Z to seven boy the grade
zero would have been something and and
here they here they instead of syllables
per word they're using letters per word
they they wanted a formula that was
easier to to to do you didn't have to
know what a syllable was um and um uh
you know there's ways of there's
algorithms for counting syllables that
are Fairly reliable based on U on vowels
and and certain patterns uh but that
this is letters per word is certainly
they can count that easily enough and
words per sentence again and so you get
another score here and then the third
formula is
um uh is by people who decided they
would instead of talking about words per
sentences they were're going to talk
about the
reciprocal um and times a Conant which
is sentences per 100
words um and then they give a they give
a score based on that and letters per
word and then there's a final score here
which is a real which is which has a
starts with a 26.8 it makes it look kind
of flaky it's it's not too uh it's
amazingly uh robust uh in the examples
that we had it didn't give us any we
readings that were way off scale but uh
you subtract syllables per word words
per sentence it's similar but uh with a
negative thing in here so so uh um
strange anyway we got these or maybe
they re scale adapter I don't sure
anyway those are four those are four
things and you get all four of them and
they say that uh for for things that uh
for normal technical paper they had felt
that the Kincade rating the one that
they give first tends to be the most uh
um correlates the best with their own
experience as at Bell apps this is by
Linda Cherry who uh who did most of this
work are we supposed to be seeking to
minimize or maximize these numbers uh
you're uh you you're supposed to say
what your what kind of a grade level
you're you're shooting for um and uh
usually though if you're shooting for I
I would try to minimize in other words I
would say um unless I unless I'm really
trying to uh uh to to make the reader
think that this you know that well
certainly if if I got too too small I
would probably
be
um uh defeating my purpose too uh if I
if I wrote
entire you know suppose I made all my
sentences four words long you know and
three words per sent three letters per
word or something like this you
know uh we could we could um we could
minimize this in fact I I do have an
example of that um coming up where I
where I tried where I tried to minimize
these scores but that's that's you're
you're you're steing my my my thunder
there um now anyway church was rated
here about 15th grade level okay now
then it says number of sentences how
many words were there the average length
of sentences Mary CLA talked about this
he's got 31W sentences okay um the uh
then has the average length of a word uh
is is a is a little less than five
letters that's that's not especially
long but then then you you you subtract
out here he says number of
non-functional words and these are the
words that aren't in um that aren't the
uh words like the and and an above which
that all the words that are used for
grammar uh the non-functional words are
the words that have uh sematic content
about the actual subject and U and the
average length to those is is is
typically more more relevant than the
average length of the of the words
including the functional words so so
this was these would tend to be longer
of course and then you talk the shortest
sentence was uh short sentence is 177%
only one example this is this is too bad
this is uh this is actually uh a small
sample size here we had only six
sentences uh but it doesn't looks like
they were all pretty long um in this
particular case the longest sentence was
uh 39 words the shortest sentence was 22
words but the average was 31 so they all
clustered they didn't spread out very
much in
length then they classifies them into
types of sentences for four kinds and U
um simple depending on how many Clauses
they have and U I won't go into the
exact details of this but there's but it
does some some analysis as to as to as
to what
variety there is a sentence structure
and the and the way they do this mostly
is by studying uh by classifying every
part of the sentence into uh type type
of word and grammar and so on and so
they they look at uh uh how many times
you used infinitives for example in
verbs um and uh uh passives how many
times was the uh uh 42% of your non-
infinitive verbs were passive in this
case instead of
active um and uh so they give uh uh then
types as percentage of the total words
so he used 12% prepositions 5%
conjunctions 7% ad adverbs you know 23%
nouns adjectives pronouns and then they
have something called nominalizations
I'm not going to say much more about it
but these are words that include shun
meant ship and other things in there he
just does a pattern match and and if
there's a certain certain um
combinations of letters in there he call
he thinks it's a nominalization and that
might be a um and if you have a high
percentage of those you might be uh
doing a high you might be writing in
high engineer
ease um sentence Beginnings says how do
you open your sentences and uh and uh we
got U uh only six sentences here so
there not much of a sample but we he
once with a noun once with a pronoun
once with an adjective once with a
preposition once with an adverb
uh pretty good variety isn't it all
different uh but more usually with the
subject anyway that's the and then he
has this funny thing here uh the uh
people who wrote style have a funny
thing that they call expletives and you
can even run this with a switch that
will print out all the sentences that
that begin with expletives now um um any
of us who are familiar with the
Watergate days will realize that uh
expletives are supposed to be deleted
right um but uh uh I looked this up in
in uh in L's dictionary and they don't
use the and they certainly don't have
the same usage of this word but what
they mean here in expletives is just
that you started the the sentence with
the word it or
there and you're just this sort of a you
know started this you say it is natural
that or
there okay now let's take a look at some
examples that that came out so this one
begins with expletive it was in a this
by the way isn't from church this is
from Paul's notes of one of my for this
CL here it was in April 1977 that Don
travels with essay they they they
changed some letters to lowercase and
others to and I don't I haven't figured
out exactly the algorithm for this um
prompted but but uh this is essay was
converted to to lowercase by the system
prompted him to investigate type setting
for himself and then they put a they put
a they separate out um punctuation to
when you see the sentences the way the
these programs are analyzing in May of
that year he designed the first draft of
te and um and another thing they do is
they look for uppercase letter following
a lowercase letter and they break that
into two words probably they're looking
at Unix program uh C programs or
something where where people do this I
don't know but they they they break that
into two words was definitely not in the
source and spent his sabatical uh and 10
more years perfecting it these these
parenthesis are not studied by these
programs at all I think they just uh
they just considered a punctuation and
don't do much with it except they except
for matching for uh they have some
patterns that that the other program the
addiction program looks at um putting
volume four of ACP on the back burner
ACP again lowercased okay sentence
length 49 that includes one for Te and
one for X if you count them you know um
so so you get penalized for that as an
extra word on that Paul but okay
compound
complex sentence so this is considered
compound complex it's the it's the
highest of the categories of the
sentence complexity uh and it says
begins with
expletive
it he didn't really begin with what I
would call an
exp uh I didn't leave this in yes right
well next time we're going to have an
exploitive that I'll delete okay now
here's another one from Tracy CH after a
brief but shaming musical prud done
demonstrated to us that we are not alone
in being concerned with the mechanics of
writing and this was this was called
passive voice uh a sentence that had
passive in it begins with a preposition
you see it begins with after uh but
passive voice not the demonstrated
that's active um not that we are not
alone that's active but in being
concerned is passive so it caught the
passive there and so if there's a
passive anywhere in the sentence it'll
it'll it'll claim you got passive and
then it'll run it with the minus P
switch which which uh prints out all
things that all sentences that have
passive
um now here's one it
says um oh this is um this is from um uh
concrete math the chapter that I showed
you some weeks ago about binomial
coefficients I showed you some excerpts
of it near the beginning of this course
so we we use the same argument we used
last chapter in showing that blah is the
number of permutations of an object now
when I made this uh when I made this
text this is another one of the texts
here uh W where is it
uh I got to keep my files in order okay
this is
binomial
2 um this comes what I did for this
example I this is I I showed you this
chapter once before remember we we took
a look at this first paragraph and Mary
CLA said I didn't have my commas right
and stuff um and what I do every time I
get to a math formula I change it to
blah but if it's displayed I change it
to
display and so uh and and unless it's a
a real short formula only one letter
long like K and then then I just left it
as
k um so uh um uh this is uh uh not going
to teach anybody binomial coefficients
but it these formulas would only have
confused that program and they and they
they they the fact the you know the
program automatically starts out and and
has a something called drough that that
takes out all the all the tr- off type
setting instructions uh and and
equations that are in it um so at least
I put in a word instead of these
equations would or narily just been
deleted the way they normally run these
program this thing anyway this is the
this is um chapter on binomial
coefficient and and I'm going to compare
this I call this binome 2 I compare this
with binome one which is um the first
which is from my volume one of the art
of computer programming where I
introduced binomial coefficients uh and
the binom T was sort of a rewrite of of
of vome 1 20 years later so so this is
uh uh you know but by the same
conventions I used for the
1965 version as for the 1985 87 version
okay um so so display blah and all this
goes in okay so that's the now here's a
sentence that comes out of that one um
and it just shows a little more of what
this program is doing inside it put the
it it it considered argument and
permutation to be nominalizations that's
what it means by
nominalizations uh a word that contains
shun is always a
nominalization and word it contains me I
don't think those are bad words
particularly but they might have been if
I had a lot of other Ms and shuns in
there okay we use the same arguments we
use last chapter showing that BL is the
number of permutations of n objects
sentence like 21
complex uh because it has you know extra
Clauses um readability nine ninth grade
level and begins with a pronoun we
pronoun right
easy there are nend choices for the
first element of the sequence for each
there are blah choices for the second
must be n choose one right and so on
until no n minus one choices for the
second and so on until there are blot
choices for the K sentence length 31
compound complex
expletive starts with there you see
readability 13th grade level begins with
exp well you can see some of the so so
it it there's a very rudimentary uh
computer analysis is going on here which
is classifying these things and then
they print up a whole bunch of
Statistics now let me show you then the
the statistics that I got on my samples
and I'll tell you more about the
samples uh I got I don't know a dozen
samples here and the first one I showed
you church and we had 14.7 and all this
the next one sample I called Goo now
here I just wanted to uh you know you
computer programs don't mind if you give
them if you give them input that might
might bore a human being
um this
was this was my my sentence here all
right
now
um you like the question mark at the end
okay yeah well but it's pretty easy to
do this with the text Ting okay
now um all right so this this was
seventh grade level by the kin K scho
butus
2.6 um in the auto index level so we
were able to get pretty
yeah ah yes okay so there we are all
right now the next uh um I I'm not it
turned out that that it gave us scores
for the whole for all these things but
but the rest of them weren't were just
cluttering up to data so I I only left
goo in at the top here uh now the next
one Tracy is the is from the class notes
that she wrote that day that we saw the
beginning of um with the Charming
musical Prelude and then Paul is is a is
an example of Paul's class notes um that
you've also read it's starts out the
story so far readers will recall that
our hero proon is locked in Mortal
Combat of Scientific American and
journal
Etc editorial hubis wonderful
sentence um that's that was Paul and
then bomal one bomal 2 I explained those
are those are um from
19656 and 196
19867 uh then I have hash hash is is
from volume three of the art of computer
programming um done in the same style as
as Bome but it's but it's a less uh less
mathematical description it's it's
talking about um algorithms More Than
Mathematics and so I I wondered if this
would be substantially different and
besides I wrote volume 3 about 5 years
later after after I'd finish volume one
uh the this part of volume 3 anyway so
um uh so here we're talking about um you
know we got blahs and displays
occasionally but not as not as often and
it's talking about uh it's introducing a
subject of
hashing and there's references and stuff
too in
here in all right next is um tech tech
is from the techbook this is something
that I wrote
um that that I wrote uh 1982
1983 uh so hash itself was written
1971 72 so that's represents 10year
period between between that and and this
is from the chapter that Jeff referred
to briefly in his talk uh about macros
and I guess lesie referred a little bit
so I thought it was it was the right
chapter to select here it's chapter 21
or something of the book so it's not at
the beginning where you would expect the
more simple chapters to be um and this
is uh so this is uh uh similar here now
I when but here I put a backlash in
because uh this would come as a felter
word because I'm referring to a a a a a
symbol here I don't know how that got
through I usually replace that by
blah okay then job is another one um I'm
writing I'm working on weekends on on a
book that has to do with religion and I
wondered if the style of my writings
about theology would be quite different
from the style
writings about mathematics and so I
tried that so here's a here's a uh um
you know it's a description of the The
Book of Job and so on so I so there's um
there's that then uh withering Heights
is the last is the withering Heights is
is of course Charlotte Bronte and I just
happen to have it online at sale and
Grim's fairy tales we took the first
fairy tale of grim so let's take a look
at the I took a sort of a withering
Heights I took a random
chapter from near the
middle or no not too far into the book
well here's the way withering Heights
looks um notice that um lot this first
person it's t it's told by the the woman
who Mr heathcliffe uh uh can right here
is Heath Cliff so so you win on
readability when you have I because it's
one letter word word and you lose when
you have Heathcliff and so on according
to these
formulas um okay but that's the um
that's withering Heights and then um
Grim's fairy tale let's
see um looks like this it's so
Charming
um in olden times when wishing still
helped one there lived a king whose
daughters were all beautiful but the
youngest was so beautiful that the son
itself which has never seen so much was
astonished whenever it Shone in her face
and this is the first uh fairy tale in
Grim's fairy
tale it is no giant but a disgusting
frog and it ends
with faithful Henry and master was set
free and was happy it's a happy ending
okay and then the other one the final
one is is this one by um one of my
heroes Colin Higgins Harold and Ma this
from the beginning I believe of Harold
and Ma Harold Jason stepped up on the
chair and placed the Noose about his
neck and miss and so on now Harald and M
is quite different style from these
other ones it's she
paused uh
okay I have a sore throat he said
softly oh well
now now now we look at the grading at
the at the reading levels that we got
from this you see uh U Harold m comes up
at fifth grade fourth grade reading
level on these on these scores
interesting um Grim's Fairy Tales um
appropriately for children I guess comes
in seventh eth eth nth grade level
withering Heights was was a sophomore
High School um and surprisingly of all
my writing that I my mine which is the
binomial 1 twoh these five in the middle
here um the uh the one about theology
was was by far was noticeably um less
opaque in the in the readability
indices um and I looked at it again to
see if I was you know what it is but
usually when you talk about your own
field you you uh uh you tend to be more
obscure than if you're talking about a
field that you're not normally normally
in I suppose um now uh so the um the CH
the difference in 20 20 25 years 20
years I guess for binomial Cod
efficients was not
substantial
uh explaining the same material at a
more leisurely Pace but still um uh uh
about the same the sentence was about
the same and when I had when I came to
hashing um it was actually uh and the
textbook itself they these are these are
U you know college freshman high school
high school level texts they had an
example in they have an example now in
um in in the uh here of uh they ran it
on article by kernahan and mashy about
Unix and uh this one came in at 12.3
12.8 now um so
so uh that's a reasonable score uh
anywhere in the in those levels and as I
said Church's book was not was not at
all ugly to read or any anyway the
sentences are kind of musical and uh so
on it just was uh
it but it was definitely a the sentences
were more complicated one by
one by these formulas okay now let's see
sentence info average length of sentence
you see so church had 32 and um in these
other texts that we're looking at and
and I I consider that the uh that most
of these specimens of writing are are uh
are are are sort of good examples um and
um Mary CLA said that she would like to
see sentences averaging length between
15 and 18 uh roughly says that but some
remember she said ought to be you ought
to have the the long sentences so that
you can deemphasize points as well as
the short sentences that that that
emphasize points you can't be shouting
all the all the while um and and uh so
um uh so well these are a little on you
know you remember church was on the high
side these are a bit these are uh a
little on the high side here my my Tas
but they're just taking notes of what
I'm saying so it's probably they have to
be longwinded um and in hashing noticed
I was up there pretty high um and uh and
with job I was down right in the right
in the right range and and Harold and M
10.8 wow that's way low uh that that's
the style of the of the of the story of
course okay n um now the average length
of of words is pretty is pretty uh
Church tended to use longer words than
everybody else but the rest of it was
pretty was pretty straight uh here um
short sentences
um what's
this this is different statistics from
the church I showed you before sry we
had two drafts of church I added more
sentences in in the final I I typed in a
couple more paragraphs because the
sample size was was was small and then I
I I ran it again so so this is this is
the readability 4 14.7 when we first
looked at this on the previous page it
was
um previous page was 14.9 so so we I
took a larger sample and I you know mo
moved the number a little bit okay so
anyway this is yeah so so now church has
has a more where are we short sentences
he has uh he has a few short sentences
and long sentences by this Criterion the
the the uh the way that the program
decides between short and long is based
on your average and and uh you you have
to Dev the significant from your average
or something in order to be classified
short like for Harold and Ma a short
sentence was less than six words for
church a short sentence was less than 27
words okay um and uh now um so we had a
reasonably good variety then in these
examples as far I can see um there was a
dir here of long sentences in Paul's
writing and uh and in Herald and
M um what do you say now this isn't now
in every case the statistic isn't
necessarily very meaningful but it does
give you something to think about that
you and and any other way any new
dimension which to look at your writing
and it leads you to think about it again
and like I said the other day uh uh
sometimes it's just that I want to that
I a paragraph didn't break very well or
I or I you know I want to I want to get
something on to face a face another
illustration so I'll look at a paragraph
a little closer than I would ordinarily
look at and then I'll think of a better
way to say that sentence so so that's
the main value of these exercises I
think um now sentence types uh and we
have four kinds of
sentences um in this classification
simple complex and so on and uh uh the
church finally got one in the simple
category when I added a few more uh few
more uh lines in there but they he
tended to go into uh um the complex more
well 4% but anyway but pretty much uh
the other ones are uh are you show a dis
distribution and and you should have a
variety I think in these uh notice
Herald and mod was the way was was the
most offs scale had had 60% simple
sentences um that was of course
appropriate to the to the uh the style
of the of this opening part of his book
um short story so
now uh he said that Harold de was his
master's thesis at UCLA in in in film
and then then uh it was made into the
the real the real film later on expanded
from his from his prototype and then and
the short St all came later uh he gave a
lecture at Stanford a couple years ago
now let's see word usage verb types um I
never was able to understand this uh the
the the write up there so I'm not going
to go on and explain what it is cuz I'm
not sure what it means auxiliary verbs I
know what these are these are like was
has been or something have these extra
words that you put in will um but I
don't think that's terribly relevant
what do we got here anything significant
church has a lot more to be verbs my my
kids in high school were had to write
essays that they weren't allowed to use
to to be any other verbs like is are was
are you know have been um and uh they
had to always have some real verb that
that did something in instead it's very
hard to do I don't um surprised
fairly good exercise I suppose um
passives passive voice uh 44% in church
that was definitely a high compared to
all the others as you'll
notice and uh but notice that the
examples of of writing from from um the
classics you know withing height scrim
and all this very low almost never did
they use passive voice maybe it's
because they're writing a novel instead
of a instead of a exquis huh maybe we
can say that
okay
now um types of words and
uh don't see
anything
particularly now the one thing you if we
apply the principles that tuft had for
presenting data you would see that that
there would be much more effective ways
to present the to present this in the
way style does and in fact there are
other Unix programs that have been
written written that take the output of
style and then it then present it in a
better way and so they parse the output
you know the way in Unix you pipe to two
programs together and so so style has
been written and nobody wants to change
that but they so they they run it and
then they take the output and then they
and then they present um waste that are
more effective at but that's in um in
newer versions of units we don't
have
um okay so uh uh I don't see what wide
differences here this is seem small
number of adjectives in Grim's fairy
tales Mark Twain did not like adjectives
he seems to have recommended that you
you avoid adjectives most of the time
and just have nouns and verbs and good
old adverbs didn't like
adjectives
um sentence Beginnings I think there was
something here uh it says how how often
did a sentence begin with a anoun or
noun phrase and uh the percentages tend
to be more than half but um but uh here
this was possibly significant see Tracy
started 86% of her sentences in that in
that handout with with noun phrases and
so this might you know this might imply
that maybe uh maybe that's too too
automatic to start to start every
sentence with a noun and and a little
more variety could be gained by by uh
uh you know 86% is pretty is pretty high
compared to these other 70 70 is is
reasonably high but 80 is is higher
going get was pretty far off scale there
otherwise they were the church almost
never started with an nountain phrase
maybe too low who knows um starting with
a preposition
adverb um and so uh this uh if we just
have almost never starting with a verb
here kind of rare
and I didn't take the statistics about
expletives which I didn't think were
great uh of great importance but they
they were kind of low in all cases so I
didn't have room for it on the page okay
so anyway you get to look at these at
these things in in a slightly different
along slightly different dimensions when
you when you see an output like this but
there's another program besides style
called diction and diction will will uh
let me show you this they they have a
list of 4 50 phrases that they look for
that uh are
possible uh no
Nos and so uh yeah can you zoom it can
you zoom in on these here you see so you
look for things like full and complete
generally agreed good and got to
gratuitous greatly minimize head up help
best help in the production of okay
hopeful well and you know also anything
that contains the so if you said
hopefully it would flag it
gr uh now you can ask you can gratuitous
yes right so now you can now then
there's a program called explain which
will explain what it thinks what it
suggests you to do but now here so
here's a so I ran it on my my first
binomial coefficient thing which I which
I wrote uh you know uh in the 60s before
I was 30 years old and and it came out
with um uh well here's here's the output
addiction you get so you look at some of
my sentences here it is a simple manner
to count the N the total bracket number
of this is what they where they caught
me um K combinations of n objects and
this colon for them does not does not
stop the sentence in the addiction
program but it continues on and so they
they think it's all one one long
sentence but they stopped after the
exclamation point which is not the end
of a sentence in this case cuz I'm
talking about
factorial okay so anyway um U but this
was a sentence that they thought they
caught me by saying number of okay then
BL the quantity blah is called a
binomial coefficient they have an
extraordinary number of applications I
hung up on this phrase number of number
of must be something bad about it okay
then it says this Tre was significant
because it was one of the first works on
probability Theory they they may be
suggested like if I say one of that I
should I should find some better phrase
okay here's due to this I got to talk
about the earliest known appearance of
binomial coefficient in a 10th Century
commentary due to hood law on that I
don't know anyway on an ancient now um
am I the only person in the world who
uses du2 in this sense I wasn't able to
find it in in in the
dictionary um they say due to means
because or or something a debt that you
owe uh to be paid like money but nobody
ever used it says du to in the sense of
somebody was the inventor of
it uh what I agree with you that's
certainly everybody does this in
mathematical writing and there's no
better way to say it but but uh what you
got a better way say a theor d so a
theorum D to so and so everybody but the
DI it wasn't in the dictionary this a
long you know and and uh yeah okay thank
you for for this but but now but if you
so so do two is one of these things that
now you see u in the um in the uh Tech
the program and uh and the texbook and
so on Addison West copy it there every
time I used do to she she she changed it
and then I had to change it
back what you to um owing to or
something it was terrible I mean yeah
there was just no there was no yeah this
is this is the this is the uh uh stylish
comfortable uh elegant way to refer to
somebody to to refer to to to who
invented a concept it seems to me say
buy uh you can say buy or of yeah yeah
but this is better I think okay so
anyway do to is complaining about here
they're going to want me to change it to
because now you can you you know that
use of of do to you know when when
somebody says doe to the bad
circumstances or something like that you
could say because of something they they
prefer that but okay now in about okay
now here it says there give a very clear
Exposition so every time I use the word
vary it's going to flag it um and I I
read once a good a good algorithm for
getting rid of varies in if you if you
overuse them in your in your writing the
first thing you do is you change it to
Dam everywhere you know so you say he
gave a damn clear exposition of
bom and then and then you then you then
you then you delete the word
there and it says it works like a
charm okay
so but now look at the next one you
think that should be taken out this one
no no I would have um I don't overuse it
in fact what what they did was it no it
doesn't I'm saying U I'm saying that
that some people think you should never
use the word very because it's because
it's like nice it just doesn't have any
it doesn't really convey any Force
anymore and and if if but if if so so
yeah so so maybe I would change it back
to very if I really believe that I ought
to have a something in there yeah but if
I say you gave a clear Exposition and I
I
wouldn't doesn't give the point that I
want to do so I as long as I'm not
overusing I think it's okay now here the
next one you see what it caught here is
a um is a wicked witch and U enough said
but it does pick those out if it looks
if they're preceded by a comma it it's
okay
yeah um literally they don't like the
word literally um bomal coefficient
satisfy literally thousands of
identities well this particular sentence
I've seen quoted in several other books
it's other people seem to have been have
liked you know
um now in fact they don't like that in
order to I got to have that but which
I'm I'm caught okay and so on so on and
so on uh very and number of sentences
280 45 phrases found among 280 sentences
in my in in the draft now I did the same
thing on binome 2 and uh and in this
time uh 107 sentences 10 phrases found
so uh I was getting fewer than 10 %
instead of something like uh
whatever uh 30 20 30% um at least over
the years that that's that's a been a
change but they still complain about
number of here they say the order of um
but they're they're they're reflecting a
different misuse of the phrase the order
of
now um uh
uh and and now the uh they said that
when when they first installed this
diction program they kept they kept
statistics about what the users did and
they found out the users would would
would make the suggested changes about
50% of the time so know diction Flags
something and then you go look at and
say do I do I really want uh do I really
mean this or would I rather change it
and about half the time people actually
actually thought that that it was going
to it was going to be an improvement but
certainly not nowhere like like 80% of
the time would they think would they
agree um with the thing now there's
another program called
explain and um and it just ask you for a
phrase and then you can you can you can
talk of phrases that I had in here I
must have had assuming that right here
assuming that n is an integer and so I
said um a phas assuming that it says use
if for assuming that so I I try to say
if and is an integer uh phrase actually
says use really for actually okay so I
said here the empty in this table are
actually zeros and so I thought maybe uh
maybe it might be better to say really
zero so I went back to the manuscript
and I looked at this and thing I was
about to change it in the file and then
I said no I like actually better uh
really make it gets my fre the cross but
I you know I thought maybe they had one
for me here in terms of says use about
instead of in Terms of hopefully avoid
usually a misplaced modifier no
comparatively avoid unless really
comparing okay now I didn't know how to
get out of the
program
but uh all right but uh okay so so
that's the explained program and and
actually I typed uh one point I typed e
with and it gave me every it gave me
almost its whole database on everything
that it would suggest you know and some
of the suggestions will sometimes hit
the mark all right any questions before
I oh yeah I want to make I got an
announcement that is uh uh on your turn
papers you had different kinds of marks
and the ones that are in red are are are
due to me so if you're if you're
wondering who to hate for certain
comments on it it's my fault and if you
don't understand what these marks mean
uh or if you like more clarification as
to why in heck I made them uh please
come see me after class now or next
Wednesday I'm I'm going to be out of
town uh we our guest speaker on Monday
but I I won't be here um so uh but I'm I
am willing to uh to actually defend my
my comments to you and and and uh and
show why I why why I made that
okay